[Musique]
merci Nathalie Delattre merci
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen on va parler beaucoup avec vous
de ce qui se passe actuellement dans le
secteur de la viticulture mais d'abord
un mot sur une question d'actualité et
cette tribune qui a été publiée par des
parlementaires de gauche et de la
majorité présidentielle pour demander la
régularisation des travailleurs et
notamment des travailleurs sans papiers
dans les métiers en tension et c'est un
sujet qui divise y compris dans la
majorité sénatorial ici est-ce que vous
vous y êtes favorable mais écoutez oui
je pense que ça part d'un bon sentiment
ça concerne entre 7000 et 10000
personnes par an alors que l'hôtellerie
restauration
déclare avoir besoin de 250 000
personnes donc on voit que l'échelle est
quand même moindre que ce que l'on peut
penser
et que oui il y a nécessité il y a des
nécessités économiques et à l'Espagne
comme une évolution il y a quelques mois
en la je pense que c'est une réflexion
que nous devons avoir encore une fois
c'est un titre de séjour d'un an
renouvelable avec des conditions très
précis c'est-à-dire résider en France
depuis au moins trois ans
il y a aussi le fait d'avoir un métier
en tension ou en zone géographique de
tension et puis avoir travaillé au moins
8 mois dans les deux dernières années je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui va dans le dans le bon sens et
j'entends aussi les préoccupations de
certains et le fait que il faut que ce
texte passe en premier au Sénat parce
que c'est ce qui permettra de trouver
certainement un compte de préoccupations
des républicains c'est leur ligne rouge
les républicains est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on connaît quand ils disent ça va
créer un appel alors ça peut peut-être
c'est vrai qu'on se dit les clandestins
vont rester donc de ce fait trois ans je
pense que ce qui peut poser problème
c'est l'automaticité du dispositif donc
je pense que la discussion d'ailleurs
les rapporteurs dans leur sagesse on dit
et bien on nous en remettons non pas à
un avis de la commission mais bien à une
discussion qui va se faire en hémicycle
pour en tirer les conclusions et le
meilleur compromis je pense
qu'effectivement il faut que l'on
travaille sur l'automaticité sachant que
quand on renvoie sur les services de
l'État aujourd'hui les services de
l'État sont noyés par ces demandes et
ont énormément de mal à pouvoir
instruire tous ces dossiers on a des
situations humaines qui souffrent de la
lenteur administrative donc il faut
regarder quel est le compromis possible
sur la maîtrise de la langue si c'est
vrai que le titre de séjour ne l'exige
pas alors qu'il exige dans d'autres
titres des séjours et en fait la plupart
la majorité des 10 000 personnes à
régulariser maîtrisent la langue au fond
ont envie de de cette de cette
intégration et puis il faut absolument
que ces métiers en tension cette liste
des métiers en tension et des zones
géographiques soit mise à niveau tous
les six mois un an donc voilà je pense
que c'est sur ces trois points que
l'article 3 peut évoluer et du coup
peut-être rassuré nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale en tout cas c'est
nécessaire parce que on voit qu'on a
effectivement des difficultés de
recrutement un recrutement sur deux post
problèmes en Île-de-France en
nouvelle-aquitaine c'est beaucoup plus
bon je suis
issue et vous êtes sûr également dans le
département viticole vous connaissez
très très bien ce secteur on va en
parler on va d'abord revenir sur l'une
des questions qui a fait débats en cette
rentrée faut-il oui ou non taxer
l'alcool on fait le point d'abord avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Alex
Pusa
[Musique]
bonjour Nathalie de
marquée par une polémique sur la hausse
des taxes sur l'alcool effectivement on
a appris au mois de juillet en lisant le
site d'information contexte et le
journal Les Echos que le gouvernement
travaillait sur une hausse des taxes sur
l'alcool alors différentes options
étaient sur la table pour apporter
quelques centaines de millions d'euros à
l'État alors qu'on le rappelle
aujourd'hui les prélèvements sur
l'alcool s'élèvent déjà à 5 milliards
d'euros et cette information est bien
elle n'a pas manqué de faire réagir tout
le secteur concerné notamment la
profession viticole et puis aussi les
élus des territoires viticoles regardez
ce que nous disait par exemple Sébastien
plat le sénateur socialiste de l'Aude je
le cite les technocrates de Bercy
devraient réfléchir sur le bon équilibre
à trouver il y a une profession des
agriculteurs et une économie qu'il faut
préserver et puis il y a un problème de
santé publique et je suis frustré que
l'on ne lutte pas assez sur le fond
comme sur beaucoup d'addiction alors la
polémique a duré quelques semaines et
puis elle a été éteinte fin août par la
première ministre Elisabeth borne
c'était sur la radio France Bleu je la
cite il n'y a pas du tout de projet et
d'augmenter les taxes sur l'alcool il y
a des taxes sur l'alcool qui sont
actualisées tous les ans avec un
plafonnement et on ne va pas changer
cette règle Nathalie Delattre vous qui
êtes élu d'un territoire viticole la
Gironde et qui défendait cette
profession viticole vous êtes soulagé
finalement qu'Elizabeth borne est éteint
la polémique oui bien sûr parce que
c'est une filière qui connaît des
problématiques depuis des années on est
dans un tunnel depuis des années on l'a
vu avec la fermeture des barres et des
restaurants pendant la covid et puis ces
menaces répétées avec le changement
climatique qui touche sur l'ensemble du
territoire nombre d'agriculteurs et de
viticulteurs et qui mettent en manger
cette filière et cette profession on le
rappelle l'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé est-ce qu'une hausse de taxes sur
l'alcool pourrait faire partie d'une
politique de santé publique alors moi ce
qui m'attriste c'est que de penser que
de la taxation la prohibition puisse
entraîner une moindre consommation je
pense que la filière et la première
affaire de la prévention à rappeler les
gestes de prévention à dire qu'il faut
boire avec modération qu'il ne faut pas
mettre la vie d'autrui en danger lorsque
l'on boit ne jamais boire seul boire
lorsque l'on déjeune Ondine à plusieurs
pour un moment plaisir mais toujours en
modération et je pense que c'est
antinomique de penser que si l'on taxe
du coup on va faire de la prévention non
non il y a je pense que les tâches
cherchent de l'argent aujourd'hui nous
demandons par rapport à nos
problématiques de mildiou de grêle
encore hier il a grêlé sur les Pyrénées
Orientales nous demandons par rapport à
ça des aides c'est à dire que prendre
dans la poche pour remettre après ça n'a
pas de sens donc cette taxation je crois
que c'est une mauvaise idée si
elle elle est véritablement pour faire
de la prévention je pense qu'il y a
effectivement le problème de la dette de
la France et et c'est pas forcément une
bonne idée de venir faire les poches des
agriculteurs même c'est pas une idée une
bonne idée du tout sur des emplois une
économie des emplois non délocalisables
et puis le problème effectivement de la
prévention et je pense que la politique
de la prévention il faut moi je le
demande depuis longtemps que nous
arrivions à la co-construire ça se passe
bien au Québec ça se passe bien en
Espagne je pense que encore une fois la
filière c'est ce qu'elle demande et
c'est ce qu'elle prône de la prévention
pas besoin de taxation pour cela on va
revenir sur les difficultés de la
filière viticole dans quelques instants
avec Alex mais d'abord on va continuer
évidemment à parler de ce sujet avec le
gouvernement a renoncé à diffuser deux
campagnes de sensibilisation sur les
risques de la consommation d'alcool de
campagne qui était prévue pour la Coupe
du monde de rugby ah oui c'est une
information révélée par la cellule
investigation de Radio France des
campagnes avaient été préparées par
santé publique France avec les slogans
suivant ne laissez pas l'alcool vous
mettre KO et quand on boit des coups
notre santé prend des coups ses
campagnes de sensibilisation elles
devaient être affichées diffusée pendant
la coupe du monde de rugby mais elles
ont été mis sous le tapis par le
ministre de la Santé François Brown en
mai 2023 et puis son successeur Aurélien
Rousseau a également refusé de diffuser
une ancienne campagne de sensibilisation
au risque de l'alcool qui datait de 2019
alors forcément et bien cette
information elle a fait grincer des
dents le médecin est sénateur socialiste
Bernard giomet jaumier regrette ce
renoncement du gouvernement je le cite
depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est élu il
n'est pas possible de mener une
politique de santé publique sur l'alcool
toute mesure destinée à inciter une
consommation plus modérée et combattue
par les lobbys et le chef de l'État cède
à cette pression espérance se
réconcilier avec les territoires
Nathalie Delattre est-ce que le
gouvernement a eu tort de renoncer à ses
campagnes de sensibilisation moi je ne
sais pas pourquoi effectivement il y a
eu renoncement parce qu'encore une fois
la filière vitic parce que on parle de
l'alcool on met souvent un verre de vin
alors qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
alcools c'est toujours le vin qui qui
est stigmatisé la Coupe du monde de
rugby quand vous allez aux abords du
stade ou dans les stades c'est de la
bière en grande majorité moi j'ai pas vu
de bon donc moi je pense que
contrairement à ce que dit mon collègue
j'ai mis non il y a eu des progressions
on voit bien que le message de
prévention c'est renforcer puisque avant
rappelez-vous il y a encore quelques
années très peu d'années on parlait de
deux verres pour les hommes un verre
pour les femmes tous les jours donc ne
pas dépasser aujourd'hui on parle divers
par semaine
donc ça veut dire moins d'un verre par
jour avec des pauses hépatiques etc donc
vous voyez bien que ce message en fait
de prévention c'est renforcé et très
vite s'est installé d'ailleurs parce que
c'est devenu la référence aujourd'hui
donc je suis désolé on fait de la
prévention il y en a le message
l'industrie etc toutes les filières ont
des demandes toutes les filières
bien évidemment exposent leurs
problématiques et tentent de montrer en
quoi les décisions certains décisions
pas toutes peuvent déstructurer la
filière donc écoutez si elle est écoutée
c'est une bonne chose parce que
effectivement nous avons besoin de
défendre cette filière on va parler des
difficultés de cette filière justement
vous parliez du mildiou tout à l'heure
c'est cette sorte de champignons qui a
attaqué les vignobles bordelais on en
est aujourd'hui comment se passe du coup
les vendanges comment vont-elles se
passer bien écoutez vous savez nous
c'est toujours un contrôle apostériori
c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a une attaque
que ça soit gel grêle ou maladie
cryptogamiques plusieurs maladies donc
de champignons
nous constatons nous avons constaté que
certains grains ne pourraient pas être
vendangés
et bien nous allons faire le calcul
l'issue des vendanges c'est à dire que
par rapport à un rendement donné moyen
que nous connaissons tous de nos vignes
on va voir quel est le manque pour
chacun donc là il est trop tôt pour
chiffrer les pertes encore trop tôt nous
n'avons pas l'habitude de de chiffrer à
priori nous avons fait une estimation
effectivement
ensuite voilà nous verrons nous ferons
le bilan à partir des rendements mais
plusieurs vignobles ont été touchés
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde parce
que c'est une un problème d'excès
d'humidité donc certains territoires
n'ont pas eu autant d'humidité que
d'autres donc oui cette chance de
pouvoir échapper
au milieu ou en tout cas d'avoir une
pression moindre et d'autres oui donc ça
va être très hétérogène certains s'en
sont très bien tirés et auront une belle
récolte d'autres auront un grain de
qualité mais moindre donc c'est là où
nous demandons que l'État met en charge
le mécanisme ce triste et vous n'avez
pas encore eu de réponse de la part de
la part de l'État on a eu la visite de
Marc seynod qui a dit qu'il
s'engagerait dans ce qui avait été
conclu puisque nous avons un système
assurantiel nous avons réfléchi avec le
ministre de Normandie à l'époque suite
au gel noir qui avait touché l'ensemble
du territoire un système qui doit
s'affiner mais là où nous avons été très
surpris et ou avec mon collègue Didier
Paris donc au président de l'Association
nationale des élus de la vigne et du vin
c'est le désistement des assureurs c'est
à dire que le président des assurances
français dit ou la présidente des
assurances français pardon dit et bien
non nous n'assurerons pas nous ne
prenons pas en charge les excès
d'humidité bien sûr que si ça demande à
être affiné c'est comme
le gel c'est peut-être qu'il faut que
l'on rajoute des pourcentages un taux de
pourcentage d'humidité d'excès
d'humidité etc mais ils ne peuvent pas
au premier coup à la première alerte et
première problématiques de ce mécanisme
assurantiel faire défaut parce que ça
veut dire que les agriculteurs ne vont
plus faire confiance dans un système
assurantiel alors que l'on a besoin
compte tenu de
de ces cycles qui ne vont plus être
exceptionnels mais malheureusement
réguliers merci à Alex merci beaucoup à
tout à l'heure évidemment dans le club
on parlera d'autres Marine Le Pen et
Jordan Bardella un autre sujet on va
c'est un sujet cette crise du secteur
viticole qui a été évoquée entre Pierre
urmik et Elisabeth borne et on va
continuer à parler de cette rencontre on
va chez vous à Bordeaux où on retrouve
Jefferson des sports bonjour Jefferson
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
je vais faire scène qui est journaliste
à sud-ouest et vous vouliez également
vous revenir sur cette rencontre entre
Pierre urmic et Elisabeth band mais sur
un autre sujet
oui exactement bonjour Oriane bonjour
Nathalie Delattre on va parler de
Bordeaux et du maire pierre-hermique
vous l'avez dit parce que vous êtes
conseillère municipal à Bordeaux
Nathalie Delattre et lundi le maire
écologiste a donc rencontré Elisabeth
borne la première ministre à Paris bien
notamment été question de la LGV la
prolongation vers Toulouse la Bordeaux
Toulouse Pierre Army qui est opposé et
début septembre l'autorité
environnementale a estimé que l'étude
d'impact de ce projet reposait sur des
données obsolètes alors Nathalie
Delattre est-ce que vous craignez une
remise en cause de ce projet grande LGV
j'aurais bien aimé pierre hermiques
nos informent du fait qu'il allait
rencontrer la première ministre je
dirais enfin parce que nous sommes dans
le top 10 des grandes villes françaises
il était temps qu'effectivement le maire
de Bordeaux rencontre qui vous a pas
informé vous allez consulter pas du tout
donc je pense que nous
j'aurais pu aussi apporter des éléments
et par rapport à cette rencontre donc
acte encore une fois il est il est
intéressant qu'il puisse qu'il puisse
être sur ce type d'entrevue
régulièrement parce que nous avions
plusieurs problématiques dont
effectivement la LGV alors je répète
aussi ma position c'est que je suis pour
la LGV mais le tracé actuel me dérange
puisque moi j'étais sur l'aménagement du
territoire au niveau France donc sur le
Paris Orléans Orléans Limoges Toulouse
donc c'est vrai que c'est cette ce
barreau Bordeaux à Toulouse aujourd'hui
moi m'intéresse plus sur la politique
des trains du quotidien ce que je ce que
je défends je pense que l'autorité
administrative a pointé effectivement
des études le préfet lorsqu'il l'a
réunit l'ensemble des élus du territoire
concerné avait déjà pointé le fait que
ces études environnementales dataient et
qu'il valait les refaire donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné de toute manière
elles seront actualisées et qu'elles ne
seront plus une problématique
malheureusement pour avancer sur sur ce
dossier ça veut dire que nous en sommes
aujourd'hui déjà 14 milliards des études
supplémentaires
l'inflation des réactualisations moi je
ne dis depuis le début que nous
arriverons à un projet de 20 milliards
aujourd'hui la problématique en Gironde
et ça ne s'oppose pas je comprends que
les Toulousains veuillent se rapprocher
de Paris il faut trouver une solution je
pense que depuis le temps qu'on a lancé
ce dossier on aurait pu aussi traiter la
problématique de Limoges qui veut se
rapprocher de Paris de toute cette zone
blanche qui veut se rapprocher de Paris
aujourd'hui les Girondins ce qu'ils
demandent c'est le plus de mobilité moi
je vais faire parvenir là dans quelques
heures un courrier et je ferai un
communiqué de presse aussi à la Rousset
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il nous
faut une vraie
multimodalité au niveau de la gare
Saint-Jean c'est à dire que les TER le
premier TGV du matin et les derniers TGV
du soir ne sont pas connectés au TER de
nos territoires donc nous sommes obligés
quand on veut venir à Paris pour
travailler une journée deux jours ou
trois jours que l'on commence tôt le
matin et que l'on finit tard le soir
avant de rentrer de prendre nos
véhicules et de venir
tous sur la rocade puis embouteillée le
quartier de la gare je pense que ça
aussi c'est un sujet qui aurait dû
évoqué pierre urique et qui est un enjeu
de taille qui va falloir régler avec la
SNCF Jefferson vous avez une autre
question Bordeaux oui je reste sur
Bordeaux rapidement Nathalie Delattre
puisque Bordeaux a un nouveau ministre
depuis cet été Thomas Cazenave qui est
au budget est-ce que ça peut être un bon
candidat pour les municipales à Bordeaux
est-ce que ça peut être un concurrent
pour vous Nathalie Delattre par exemple
écoutez moi je d'abord je félicite
Thomas d'avoir accédé à ce poste je
pense que ça va aider bien évidemment la
ville de Bordeaux c'est un c'est un
partenaire vous savez les élections
municipales c'est dans 3 ans on a
tellement de défis à remplir lui et moi
avant et vous y pensez déjà peut-être
tout le monde y pense visiblement
comme dirait Édouard Philippe
on va continuer à se projeter Nathalie
Delattre vous étiez à Tourcoing fin août
pour la rentrée politique de Gérald
Darmanin on s'est croisé d'ailleurs je
couvrais cet événement pour sud-ouest
est-ce que ça vous parle Darmanin 2027
Nathalie Delattre si on continue à se
projeter bien entendu en tout cas ça
fait partie de ces ministres qui
ont l'autorité qui
ont la proximité nécessaire pour parler
aux Français je pense que c'est
important
que nous puissions en tout cas déjà
rassurer les Français pour dire qu'il y
aura et qu'il y a des personnes
habilités en capacité
de pouvoir se présenter en 2027 parce
que malheureusement on parle trop
souvent que de uniquement de Marine Le
Pen et d'un tel je crois que c'est
rassurant de savoir que plusieurs
personnalités sont capables en tout cas
en 2027 de se présenter et c'était le
sens de ma venue ça peut pas dire que
pour vous c'est Gérald Darmanin le mont
candidat écoutez encore une fois là
c'est 4 ans donc
en 4 ans il se peut se passer beaucoup
de choses on le voit il y a des
mouvements sociaux on fait face à des
crises répétées on a une guerre sur un
notre continent donc c'est un peu tôt
mais je trouve que ce n'est pas trop tôt
pour certains de se déclarer Edouard
Philippe et déclaré depuis un an et demi
je pense que c'est plutôt rassurant de
voir que nous avons des des
personnalités en capacité et nous aurons
bien d'autres je pense candidature d'ici
là donc
je pense qu'il faut rester par rapport à
ça très lucide et humble merci Jefferson
est-ce que vous avez une préférence un
atelier Delattre
de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui avec lequel
je travaille
Édouard Philippe est une personnalité
que je vois régulièrement voilà et donc
nous verrons cela en temps et en merci
Jefferson Jefferson on va regarder la
Une de Sud-Ouest parce que évidemment
c'est c'est un sujet d'inquiétude un
sujet concernant sardines contaminé la
mort dans l'assiette ça fait référence à
ces cas de botulisme qui ont été
détectés suite à
des gens qui ont consommé des sardines
en conserve dans un restaurant de
Bordeaux il j'ai eu une personne qui est
décédée d'autres qui sont dans des états
graves vous êtes élus municipal est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiète
comment vous avez réagi à cette
information
en fait ce qui est bien c'est que cette
information soit diffusée le plus
rapidement possible évidemment notre
quotidien régional Sud-Ouest mais dans
les journaux français et internationaux
parce que nous étions ce week-end là en
Coupe de monde de rugby où nous
recevions il y a eu énormément de
passages
d'étrangers on le voit il y a un cas qui
survenu à Barcelone qui fait partie de
ce foyer bordelais ça rappelle que faire
des conserves ce n'est pas neutre ça
peut engendrer des problématiques c'est
généralement plutôt un problème
domestique c'est-à-dire chez des
personnes privées c'est très rarement
dans l'hôtellerie restauration ça montre
effectivement que les hôteliers
restaurateurs doivent faire attention
redoubler vigilant je crois que c'est
vrai que ce sont des choses quand on ne
rappelle pas suffisamment mais bon là il
y a des mesures qui ont lâcher prise
pour que l'on puisse retrouver une
dizaine de personnes qui peuvent être
concernés parce que l'alerte
les signaux peuvent arriver jusqu'à
dimanche il faut les détecter le plus
vite possible parce que cette personne
qui est décédée était en bonne santé ça
a basculé très vite il faut très vite se
mettre sous
respiration voilà assister voilà donc
c'est important qu'on puisse en parler
c'est vrai que bon pour Bordeaux c'est
c'est une information difficile mais
voilà il faut que l'on fasse toute la
transparence sur ce sujet et le message
est passé merci de Jefferson c'est la
Une de Sud-Ouest évidemment on l'a vu
ensemble il y a un autre sujet auquel
vous intéressez particulièrement ce sont
les questions de laïcité la rentrée
scolaire a été marquée par ce débat sur
le port de la baillargue Gabriel Attal a
voulu très vite clarifier les choses
est-ce qu'il a eu raison de le faire oui
évidemment c'est une demande qui avait
les directeurs d'école depuis un moment
je pense que vous savez moi j'ai
beaucoup sur un les sujets de laïcité
mais aussi j'ai été présidente de la
commission d'enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste avec comme
rapporteur Jacqueline stage brignaud je
crois que ce que l'on a constaté déploré
qu'on déplore depuis longtemps c'est que
beaucoup de politiques avons été naïf en
fait preuve d'angélisme et surtout de
manque de courage de prendre des
décisions parce que là on a un ministre
qui a pris une décision une décision
on peut effectivement un moment donné la
mesurer l'étudier voire si on est allé
trop loin ou pas mais en tout cas oui il
y avait une demande il y a une décision
courageante encore une fois
l'école fait partie de la République
laïque nous avons une école républicaine
et laïque ce temps décolle doit être
préservée de toutes ces questions là
j'ai bien entendu que certains disaient
mais non c'est plutôt un instrument de
mode etc
en dehors de l'école c'est à dire que
elle n'est pas interdite en dehors des
temps d'écoles donc voilà on peut
l'exprimer différemment en tout cas je
pense que s'il donne bonne mesure ça
montre que l'uniforme à l'école règle
aurait bien des problèmes pour aussi moi
je suis pour depuis un moment sur
l'uniforme à l'école on va terminer sur
un autre sujet scolaire puisque vous
avez signé avec d'autres parlementaires
une tribune avec également des
représentants de parents des
spécialistes de l'enfance une tribune
sur la nécessité de faire de l'hygiène
et de la sécurité des toilettes
scolaires une priorité quel est
l'ampleur du problème aujourd'hui et
quelles sont les conséquences écoutez
oui moi c'est un sujet dont je me suis
emparé mon aîné à 21 ans dont je me suis
emparée très tôt quand j'ai été parents
d'élèves et je vois que ça ne s'améliore
pas aussi vite que ça ne devrait
huit enfants sur 10 se retiennent
d'aller aux toilettes à l'école donc
c'est embêtant parce que ce sont des
infections urinaires des cystites des
enfants qui ne s'hydratent pas certains
enfants vont jusqu'à dire qu'ils ne
boivent pas pour ne pas aller faire pipi
sur ce temps d'école donc pourquoi parce
que par exemple pour les garçons avoir
des urinoirs comme chez les adultes non
c'est un moment on se construit où on se
compare on sait pas toujours facile donc
en fait il faut avoir des toilettes
fermées
individuels propres où on a du papier et
puis ce sont aussi des zones de nombreux
et ça je crois qu'on l'a noté sont des
zones harcèlement des zones de début de
trafic parce que il n'y a pas assez
d'adultes qui passent régulièrement dans
ces wc dans ses toilettes
il y a vraiment toute une réflexion à
avoir et repensé effectivement la place
des toilettes dans l'école et c'est
l'objet de cette tribune merci Nathalie
de merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin